welcome to this video and playing
Duquesne if I remember this explanation
correctly about pronouncing this from
the US and we got an English opening
hatch maybe on the Queen's Indian type
in position ok he castles hmm yeah
rookie one is the possible move or be
three ya b3 is leading to the reti
opening his play with an early night BTW
seven months a possible line my plan is
some yeah maybe maybe this isn't even
the right way to do things here I wonder
body for what about a form hmm yeah
after d4 yeah after default some learn
pieces are not quite right for white but
this also applies to black's pieces the
bishop won't be too is so a bit strange
okay but um yeah black's pieces are not
particularly great as well for the
structure who came so does threaten to
take
I can take with the night let's prepare
a quick fo here okay he's open to be
found but yeah I don't like the double
pole this should give me some some
dynamic play on the gphone okay he's
using the airport that it isn't driven
too much I think Rock g1 blunders is
porn so I better protect the phone okay
yeah this isn't good news is a good move
at limits this Machado this I should
have found taken into account
but just just looking at this with
concrete moves what happens if i take
Bishop takes Queen takes friends met on
mate on g7 and it's not even easy
together and what are you play now
there's g7 under attack waiting
threatening Bishop g5 check and mate mid
next move I'm not quite sure how black a
defense against that can move the king
but done it's still very dangerous at
least it appears to be if you move the
king let's say 2 h8 I can maybe just
capture it's a check aunt in the book
it's a bit of a self pin but i can
double quickly hmm why do I have some
others after after King age 8 I have
Bishop g5
we should be five is a simple you know
yeah this is this is of course Mary
loosening so just the check and then
just this check
it's definitely dangerous for black
on rook t2 may be anticipating the
doubling preparing the doubling on the
gphone not quite sure after worked it to
whatever to smoke receive okay let's do
that job blacks on the ropes but what is
the right move maybe this isn't so bad
it's also look be to maybe as a
potential threat yeah this is
interesting not be too this is a
substantial threat pinning the bishop
now he is very much penty anyway the
night move so I can take b7 the rock
more subject a night so black's pieces
are all somewhat tied together they are
not really coordinating well yes this is
some prevents this this group b tools
hmm
I take now look checks and rugby too
yeah he's in the spin now and if he
takes rook takes it looks some very
tricky maybe queen aah chak maybe queen
ahead I would have Queenie 6 check this
is this is this is very very strong
Queenie 6 check is no a thread yeah this
is this is quite cute check and totally
designs of black resigns I saw this very
late this this idea what is some somehow
no not really working before yeah very
interesting after this I completely
overlooked f5 this idea and this is a
from a positional point of view
interesting move because it fixes this
porn on a form of sorry it fixes this
pawn here so my bishop is hemmed in this
is actually the bishop that was the the
piece to sacrifice on age 6 later but
now this is impossible but maybe this is
just not working for technical reason I
took here and this probably losses due
to Queenie 7m it does lose computer
gives plus 5 it's just too much the g7
and there's also this the spinning ideas
you played this and now the easiest is
okay yeah this is much easier I think
rook t2 wasn't bad probably it just
keeps it keeps the winning position at
least but this is much easier takes
takes and and just just just this check
check check yeah this is spinning like
this this is some relatively easy but
this this keeps the keep the winning
hand Chang it's not they're not the only
way to play but it's it's enough and
after that he resigned so f5 was some
interesting strategically but not really
working he needs to do some kids play
some other mousse maybe a a preparation
for this like a look of age or something
it's a complicated position maybe black
ass in good shape here I thought the G
file would be a man important factor but
this idea is really strong hmm yeah I
don't think white is a worse or
something but I am sort of hope to have
fun an advantage here but this doesn't
seem to be the case let's say Norman
Luffy is going to go by five this is
just better now it's a much more
coordinated way to play a five yeah
interesting they're interesting blog
game alright thanks for watching